Without even knowing the world because
we didn't have any of the other chemical
fertilizer and so forth.
So we know how to do it.
We know what sustainable,
we knew how to very crap so that the,
we don't,
uh,
you know,
diminish the quality of the earth and so
forth.
So we know how to do that.
We know how to use a natural fertilizer
and all that.
So it's not that we don't know it a
little more work and the food is ship.
The food is to ship in this country.
If it was a little more expensive and
people will come in,
drove.
And apparently the,
the,
the organic market is working 20% up
every year.
And so it's been moving and incredible
speed,
but it's still very expensive for
certain people.
By the time that it will be only 30 or
40% more than regular product,
people are going to move in,
drove,
you know,
to,
to organic product.
And we should,
I believe so.
I believe that the,
even when I was at Howard Johnson,
everything that you can,
uh,
you can produce well,
especially now with new technique of
Soviets and other innovation in
technology that come about,
if it's done with the best product to
start with,
it will cost money.
I mean,
there is great product now which come
from Spain for example,
can product with new way of canning,
which,
uh,
don't have to be retarded that is cooked
so long so that it diminish a great deal
of the taste in the,
so there is all kinds of new innovation.
Yes,
I absolutely believe that technically we
will be able,
we already able to do food which tastes
great and are healthy and are good for
you and are absolutely delicious,
which is what sandbox.